as hand I speak with the king's voice on  this  and all other matters  tomorrow the high Towers land there  but those vipers rule in my father's  name  he's Landing then  this snake has taken a grave wound him  back in Step stairs  who will take the Driftwood Throne the  crown can stand strong at the house of  the Dragon remains divided  this is a matter of blood not ambition  this is a trap nephews  threat of War lose  for free you can now listen to the  entire audiobook Fire and Blood On which  house of the Dragon is based and which  covers the entire Targaryen history  including current and future events of  House of the Dragon for free with a  notable trial using our Link in the  description